[Music]
to another exciting episode the Kos and
I bring you the third player in DC's
Holy Trinity Superman this is the og
Premium Format statue from sideshow now
I gave you the modern take on Superman
remember that one that's the one with
Brainiac and he's standing on the
Brainiac base the suit is a little bit
different it doesn't have the red trunks
also the only mixed-media on that
statute is Decatur this one is a little
bit different this is the Superman from
one of my favorite comic books whoa he
looks like it I think it's like that did
they call it like earth Prime so he is
Superman from kingdom come
now all he needs is the white streaks in
the ceiling we which it so iconic
he's so how we grew up for you know the
Superman back in the days was you know
the Christopher Reeve Superman this is
how he is he's a little bit more
stronger looking older looking more
powerful more stout and the pose is just
like a real museum type pose so we all
know you know he came from Krypton as a
child and he came to earth but let me
give you the reason why I like the
statue and why I got the statute but
first I'm gonna actually like follow
subscribe and make sure you hit that
notification bell so the next time KL
West pops up you can get that alright so
I like King I like the the kingdom come
storyline because it it was done so well
it was it was painted and it was a great
read the book was fantastic you know you
have classic battles and it's something
that I think every fan of the DC
Universe should exactly we you know you
should definitely pick that up and get a
good read out of it but you will see
classic heroes done in a mature like you
know it's a they're dealing with real
world
there's a little bit more current like
like you see Superman here he has a more
mature vibe to him so you definitely get
a big feeling of the gravitas of the
book is it's weighted in that world you
know it kind of reminds me of the
Superman from Batman vs Superman from
The Dark Knight Returns Superman the old
school the classic the strong you know
Clark Kent the big guy and I think they
went away from that character I think
they got bored with that character so
they had to change different elements of
him to make them you know more current
more hip and because I guess he started
to feel like like you know like your old
uncle or something so I needed to have
this statute to finish my Holy Trinity
remember I have Batman I have Wonder
Woman oh gee and I have Superman oh gee
Holy Trinity but I also have the modern
Holy Trinity and I'm gonna do a
comparison video like which which
statute did it better you know so let's
dive into this statute here and what
makes this statute a whole lot different
from the modern tape
well this statute I have a custom cake
that's the Cape that you see that's on
them right now
that custom Cape is a mixed-media Kate
this fabric it has a wire frame that's
along the bottom that you compose it
into any direction so I wanted it you
know to be out I wanted to show the
majesticness of Superman and the resin
cake on the poly stone Cape you can see
here it's very heavy
it's stuck it doesn't move it's you know
molded and that's basically you know how
it is so and you don't get this cake you
know from sideshow when you order it
this is a special custom cake that I had
done and made for me for this particular
statue
it comes with to switch out portraits a1
with his heat vision actively in use and
you have to place the little heat vision
intros and his eyes so it looks like
it's like smoking coming out and it's
it's it's a very beautiful effect but I
won't be displaying it that way I will
be displaying it just how you see it
right now with the majestic looking up
like Clark is looking up to the sky and
his hands is poised just right the whole
suit is mixed-media and remember when I
told you guys that that means is made
out of fabric
and you know you have to be really
careful with mixed-media it's um it
looks very nice it doesn't hold up over
time and you fit you know over a period
of time it will wear and it will get
older that's why a lot of times on the
sideshow just goes with like full poly
stone or full resin of statues but you
know I love the look I love the distinct
contrast that you have against the older
I mean the newer Superman versus the
older one I love the base because the
base actually you know tells like a
little story you know the base is of
Krypton of the fortress of solitude and
where he's from so it is a very
good-looking base to me because he's
standing in the fortress of solitude and
he's looking out at the world to see who
he has to save next so this is the part
in the video where I'm gonna ask you
again if you like what you see you know
like follow unsubscribe and also go to
the Lords of gaming dotnet but we have
all the information on the new trade
shows reviews opinion pieces just new
stuff in the gaming community that you
might like and you can get episodes of
iron Lords podcasts that I'm part of and
you can also get to chance to watch Lord
addicts are hard gaming reviews man do
you get a chance to see how to play
these games and actually reveal I don't
know man I think he's in a competition
and I think he's winning because I don't
think these guys can beat these hard
games the way he does and also you can
go to the Lords of game mechanic to get
the last word with Lord Cognito and Eve
on tests right now Destiny's getting
ready drop that DLC and we have division
we have
apex legends we have for tonight we have
a ton of Lucas shooters and Borderlands
drops this week so you already know
they're gonna be all over that game
giving you exactly the nooks and
crannies inside so stick around for the
video at the end so you can see this
statue in all its glory and also stay
tuned next week but when I bring you
somebody that's been cutting his way to
get to you guys young guys with an
accent for see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]